poland senate is preparing to vote today
on plans to build a 350 million euro
wall along its border with belarus
warsaw wants to stop migrants who've
been trying to cross from belarus into
european union territory the war would
bolster already existing security
measures along the 400 kilometer border
they include fences patrols and a three
kilometer wide exclusion zone
the eu's eastern borders have become an
unexpected entry point for asylum
seekers ever since tensions with belarus
leader alexander lukashenko fled last
year
this strip of land between belarus and
poland has become a purgatory for
migrants they say that if they try to
enter poland the border guards push them
back if they try to go back to belarus
the border guards often beat them and
send them back toward poland
water is a problem because
more time seven times the back back back
bruise and balloon
and what um what sorts of conditions are
you in what tell me
what's going on
you're not wearing shoes
it's not wearing shoes because
the legs
belarus has suddenly become a
well-trodden migration route to the eu
this summer hundreds then thousands of
migrants showed up at the eu's
northeastern border many of them hoping
to travel onto germany catching
authorities in poland off guard it
didn't take long for warsaw to come up
with a theory why belarus was sending
them in retaliation for eu sanctions on
president lukashenko's government
relations between minsk and brussels
have been bitter since the eu accused
lukashenko of stealing national
elections in august 2020 the spat
escalated when minsk forced down an
international flight in order to arrest
a political dissident
on each occasion brussels ramped up
targeted sanctions on the belarusian
government
lukashenko has denied any tit for tat
reactions but his administration eased
visa restrictions for people flying from
iraq after the last round of sanctions
and the number of daily flights between
the two countries greatly increased
many migrants say that once they arrived
they were escorted to the polish border
by belarusian soldiers
the arrival of thousands of migrants at
once has caused political chaos but it's
the migrants who are suffering the most
the standoff has left them waiting in
inhumane conditions on the belarusian
border where so far eight people have
died
well let's bring in our correspondent
magdalenic voice in warsaw magdalena the
senate is going to vote on a new wall to
stop migrants from crossing from belarus
are we expecting to get a final decision
today
well they are planning to vote today but
for now there is a big discussion being
held in the senate um so we don't know
how it will end and they should make a
decision today since they had two weeks
to make it and today is the last day
when they could do it and we don't know
how it will end because the opposition
is divided in that case so it's also a
big test for the unity of the opposition
in poland apart supports the building of
about a year and a part is not
for it and there are big concerns about
the way how the project is being proceed
in a very speedy way um avoiding public
tenders avoiding czech site effects on
environment avoiding talks with the
citizens so it's a big topic here in
poland a big issue and the result is
still unclear for now
so if this goes ahead magdalena what
form will it take how project will how
big a project will this have to be
well um we hear often that there is
going to build a wall on the border this
is of course a very symbolic picture
something which is very easy to imagine
but what we know for now is actually
that it will be a height permanent
barrier with a motion sensors on the
border we know it will be high we know
it will permanent and we know it will be
expensive as you already said about 300
millions of euros
will be they want to spend on it but how
it will finally look like it's going to
be
discussed given the cost you alluded to
and the message it sends in the region
is the notion of a wall supported by the
polish people
well in general there is a big support
for those strict politics which the
ruling party law and justice is
proceeding here in poland with the
migrants from the very beginning
you should remember they put very um
very very fast and
september state of emergency along the
border and more than 50 percent of polls
do support uh this decision until uh
today but you know on the other hand we
see a lot of helping hands here in
poland and the eastern part of the
country and also coming from the other
parts of poland people who are going
there to the woods bringing the migrants
food and water and you know emphasizing
these other aspects there's these are
people who are
needing help in those times
magdalena gavorce in warsaw thank you
you